Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
By the way, do you guys know what's the difference between...
..."I envy her" and "I'm jealous of her" is?
Alright. "I am jealous of her" has a very negative tone.
It means that you're really, really upset about what's happening to that person.
So, don't use "I'm jealous of her",...
...but you should use "I envy her".
This is a really good meaning.
It means that you have respect for what's happening to that person.
So, if something good has happened to that person,...
...and you wanna be like them say, "I envy her", okay?
Alright. Now, today's topic...
Poor you.
Poor him.
Poor me.
And second...
Lucky you.
Lucky him.
Lucky me.
Okay, let's practice.
Please repeat after me.
Oh, poor you.
Good, good.
Okay. Now, Lucky me.
Please repeat.
Good.
Alright, that's it for today.
And see you next week on Native Maestro, and we will help you become the native maestro.
Bye-bye!